bello a tutti ragazzi e benvenuto questo
video sono fa vj è questa maglia mi
rende virile parecchio direi anche direi
che possiamo iniziare con i blog i
ragazzi prima di tutto ma sei tu o meno
ogni [ __ ] blog da un anno a questa
parte direi che possiamo iniziare con la
fama della settimana ragazzi che questa
settimana è stata vinta la monica che ha
fatto data forse non troppo cucciolo zoe
in questa foto mi strapazza rei di
coccole però il cappello il cappello
originale più bello e non ce ne è
comunque ragazzi detto questo dire che
possiamo passare alle news questa
settimana gazineo a bomba proprio le
parole anche il papa praticamente alla
primissima news che volevo dirvi ragazzi
che sto facendo il sito nel quale
metterò poi tutti i contenuti facebook
instagram tutto quanto sto facendo il
sito perché lo volevo fare in un pezzo
perché fa figo avere il sito proprio la
seconda news ragazze che dalla prossima
settimana e qua sono eccitatissimo
questa cosa repubblica mi ha chiesto di
iniziare una serie che farà punto su
repubblica che preghiera che si chiama
in di of the week che è praticamente
ragazzi una serie che farò ogni due
settimane dove limite l'episodio sarà su
un indie sul indica mia colpiti colpito
di più durante le settimane è come molti
ragazzi la news più importante di tutte
qua tenetevi forte perché è incredibile
il mio migliore amico per natale mi ha
regalato questo che è un televisore che
non so chi cazzo cento pro volevo
condividere la sua magnificenza con
tutti voi
[Musica]
che era la smetto direi che possiamo
concludere qualcosa news perché stiamo
andando nel nel trash leggermente
perfetto l'arni mi paghi di oggi gen
europa abbastanza strana che voglio
farvi notare coprirne tre ragazzi sono
questi qui è questo qua è il più grande
di tutti pro guardate sta cosa già un
attimo qua la videocamera ragazzi questo
è un bicchiere di plastico che io so che
vedete ragazzi del pacco più piccolo di
tutti lo appoggio e fin qua va bene
questo è il pacco più grosso in assoluto
di tutti non sto tenendo lo sto facendo
un cazzo che hai questo ragazzi e
l'ultimo pacco che mi avete che apre
oggi questo sarà l'ultimo è un po più
piccolo degli altri e guarda che roba
che cazzo c'è dentro un transformer
io non so che pesa una tonnellata ed è
più piccolo non so che cazzo c'è dentro
vive di lasciarlo per ultimo quello
ragazzi partiamo dal più piccolo che è
meglio alla ragazza la scatola nera è
già e già sta cosa mi preoccupa
abbastanza dio che cazzo ci ho paura di
aprirsi conio dire oh mio dio mi
prendete per occhi grazie grazie
bene andrò sovrappeso cioè vero anche
perché mi sa che non vado in sovrappeso
che cosa c'è in essa mi come un
braccialetto guarda fax mio dio perché
c'è una maschera da troll face on off
sono più figo di prima mano non secondo
pacco che mi sembra abbastanza leggero
questo e confronto all'altro almeno la
figaggine lista visto paco la carta
igienica
se voi mi spiegate perchè c'è della
carta igienica in un pacco del sinai
regalato un bavaglino hello kitty ma
perché mi regalatelo kitty nei parchi
ragazzi la mia persona e un bambino
fammi capire ma guarda che roba
ma perché a me perché
no proprio no proprio no direi di andare
con l'ultimo pacco che almeno in pesante
non sarà roba per bambini credo non è
mai impacchettato una roccia grossa così
mela in via nel è possibile il mio team
cosa è un kebab un salame grazie
affinché bello unica ragazzi c'è una
delle cose con scritto pasticceria mi ha
inviato roba da mangiare amico perché fa
bene son magro però non ha senso sta che
ho camminato che devo vedere cosa c'è
statista cosa la vita la vita dei o mio
zio che io io ti sposo chiamo ti
abbraccio col dove abiti amico mio non
so chi tu sia ma ti adoro veramente
trovato un altro se ne va vj dice no al
colesterolo ma [ __ ] manco per il
pen
dopodiché ragazzi ci sono delle cialde
per il caffè io non bevo il caffè pro
grazie e regalato una borsa io sono un
maschio va ma questa cosa è molto trendy
e per ultimo ma non meno importante una
vaschetta na di miele gesù credo con
tutto il mio cuore che chi mi ha inviato
sto pacco forse mia nonna giusto per
farmi mangiare un po di più non lo so
ragazzi ma il pacco non era il mio ok ho
scartato
non so quanto di roba non era mio ben
successa la cosa che io temette ho
sempre temuto da quando ho iniziato a
fare gli spacchettamenti ho aperto un
pacco che non era mio ragazzi perfetto
chiunque dovesse ricevere quella borsa
dei semi e sarò fashion vale ragazzi
possiamo farvi risponde che è meglio in
questo caso francesco fontanone favino
perché in alto testamento e vi do c'è un
omino con una lanterna
salve sì un po meno volgare nei tuoi
prossimi video e tirava ti ringrazio
innanzitutto ti ringrazio innanzitutto
per il commento e ti rispondo con un
video che avevo fatto tempo tipo un anno
e mezzo fa al quale rispondevo già
questo domani comunque raga devo
riuscire a contenermi in questo episodio
perché non voglio che voglio cercare di
essere meno volgare possibile che cazzo
succede
spero che sia tutto a posto favi ci fai
una tizia che ha scritto questo nome ma
io ti amo poi vi ci fai vedere quello
che vedi tu quando registri un blog
non capisco il perché di questa cosa
però va beh quando registro blog ragazzi
io vedo questo è una roba ti odio ti fa
favi jackson ragazzo ho scoperto il
mondo cioè ovviamente se tu punti la
webcam sullo schermo diventa un
inception ma che figo e ragazzi cè un
mio dio come questa cosa non l'ho
scoperta prima io passerò le mie
giornate così adesso panova ragazzi ho
trovato il mio nuovo scopo nella vita
basta con ragazzi a porti e sta cosa
bella che ho scoperto adesso quindi so
come riempire le mie giornate da oggi in
avanti dire lì passa la prossima domanda
comunque grazie avermi fatto scoprire
sta comunque non vedo un inception io
vedo la mia bella faccia per quanto
possa essere belle corrisponde fare ci
sono di qualcosa con l'anci pad non lo
rifà perché ci metto anni vi mando il
video che avevo fatto messo su facebook
solido qua
metto un attimino suo pezzo poi basta
[Musica]
iole che dj fari dj problema di computer
ragazzi mi faccio la mia fari domanda
che come al solito nello scorso blog mi
sono dimenticato di fare alzheimer e la
fuochi domanda di oggi ragazzi e secondo
voi quel pacco li di chi cazzo è una
rispondo se qualcuno di voi dovrà
ricevere quel pacco melo sia nei
commenti e sappia che io mi mangerò 12
chili di dolci
quindi ragazzi spero che il video vi sia
piaciuto commerce e video è piaciuto
questo momento mi piace anche a faccia
di facebook e come non i video trovate
la descrizione serse l'avresti mai
felici diventiamo un prossimo video bene
ragazzi